ANITA: AND THE PEOPLE KEEP
COMING.
DAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GRIFF.
GRIFF: FOR MORE ON THIS JOINING
ME NOW FORMER IMMIGRATION AND
CUSTOMS DIRECTOR TOM HOMAN, TOM,
THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME AS YOU
MAY HAVE SEEN, I JUST GOT LACK
LASTBACKFROM CARAVAN LAST NIGHT
MEXICO.
THEY ARE, INDEED, MAKING IT TO
THE U.S., 4,000 STRONG.
IT’S INTERESTING, THIS ONE IS
MADE UP OF SO MANY CHILDREN,
1200 KIDS AND WOMEN WITH BABIES.
IT’S INTERESTING.
THE NEWS OF THE WEEK THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKING FOR
REPARATIONS IN SEPARATION OF
CHILDREN ON TOP OF THE
ADMINISTRATION SAYING THAT THEY
ARE SEEKING TO TERMINATE MPP,
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS?
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, FAMILY
MEMBERS 450,000 IS RIDICULOUS.
WE ARE PIE PAYING WHO ENTERING T
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY?
WHAT MESSAGES ARE WE SENDING TO
CARTELS AND FAMILY UNITS?
COME ACROSS THE BORDER AND
COMMIT A CRIME AND YOU WILL
NEVER BE PROSECUTED BECAUSE WE
DO NOT WANT TO GET SEPARATED.
DIFFERENT SET OF RULES FOR
MIGRANTS.
YOU PUT THIS ON TOP OF THE NO
ENFORCEMENT POLICY THAT CAME OUT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT, THE NEW ICE
PRIORITIES, ICE CAN’T ARREST
SOMEBODY FROM BEING HERE
ILLEGALLY, THEY STOPPED BUILDING
THE BORDER WALL.
IT’S BRINGING MORE PEOPLE INTO
THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
THEY HAVEN’T DONE ANY
ENFORCEMENT STRATEGY, NO
CONSEQUENCE, NO DETERRENCE, JUST
MORE AND MORE ENTICEMENTS.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
BIGGEST BORDER CRISIS IN THE
COUNTRY.
HISTORIC NUMBERS NEVER BEEN SEEN
BEFORE AND THEY JUST KEEP
COMING, MORE POLICIES THAT SEND
A MESSAGE, COME TO THE UNITED
STATES ILLEGALLY.  YOU GET
RELEASED IN THE UNITED STATES
YOU NEVER HAVE TO LEAVE.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, YOU CAN GET
A JOB LEGALLY NOW AND YOU DON’T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT ICE TO
ARREST YOU.
GRIFF: TOM WE COVERED THIS A
LOT, YEARS AGO CARAVAN FROM
HONDURAS TO EAGLE PASS, TEXAS,
THAT’S WHERE THEY CROSSED IN
2019 DURING THAT CARAVAN.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU A PICTURE I
PUT UP TO DAY, IT TELLS THE
STORY OF THE CARAVAN, THE
INCENTIVES THE ADMINISTRATION IS
GIVING PEOPLE, THIS WOMAN
WALKING IN 90-DEGREE HEAT SHE
CAME FROM NICARAGUA.
WALKING AND SHE’S SMILES BECAUSE
I’M TAKING HER PICTURE.
THIS IS REALLY THE TRAGEDY OF IT
WITH SO MANY WOMEN AND CHILDREN,
THERE’S MORE THAN 100 BABIES
UNDER A YEAR OLD IN THIS AND
THEY BELIEVE THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION WANTS THEM TO
COME ONE MIGRANT FROM EL
SALVADOR NAME WILLIAM TOLD ME,
QUOTE, TELL BIDEN WE ARE COMING.
IS IT YOUR BELIEF THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS INTENTIONALLY
TAKING THESE -- THESE -- MAKING
THE DECISIONS TO INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE TO COME LIKE THIS
CARAVAN?
TOM: ABSOLUTELY, THIS IS OPEN
BORDERS.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN RAN ON THE
PROMISES AND KEPT THE PROMISES.
YOU CAN’T POINT TO ONE THING
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE TO
SLOW THE FLOW.
I ADVISED THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS, WHAT’S THE NUMBER ONE
PEOPLE THING SAY TO YOU, I COME
HERE TO GET A JOB.
THEY ARE NOT SEEKING FEAR AND
PERSECUTION FROM HOMELAND.
THEY ARE COMING TO GET A JOB.
WHAT’S THE FIRST THING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DID IN RESPONSE
TO THAT, THEY SENT A MEMORANDUM
OUT TO ICE AGENTS, YOU CAN NO
LONGER DO ENFORCEMENT
OPERATIONS.
WHAT CAN WE DO, THIS IS OPEN
BORDERS, NOT MISMANAGEMENT.
NOT INCOMPETENCE THIS IS BY
DESIGN AND THIS IS GOING TO
CONTINUE BECAUSE THE ACTIONS
THIS ADMINISTRATION SPEAKS
LOUDER THAN THE WORDS.
600,000 RELEASES IN THIS
COUNTRY, 400,000 GOT AWAYS, THEY
HAVE NO FEAR FROM ICE OR THE
JUDICIAL COURTS.
GRIFF: UNBELIEVABLE, TOM, ALSO
LAST NIGHT I REPORTED THE
BREAKING NEWS TODAY, THE MIGRANT
CARAVAN WAS OFFERED WORK VISAS
FOR THE WOMEN IN THE CARAVAN
WITH CHILDREN.
THEY TURNED IT DOWN AND
CONTINUED MARCHING.
TOM HOMAN, THANK YOU FOR TAKING